et hier soir m6 diffusait le cinquième
numéro de mariée au premier regard le
programme a rassemblé 2,3 millions de
téléspectateurs sa baisse en forte
baisse sur une semaine
ils ont perdu trois cent soixante dix
neuf mille téléspectateurs pourtant moi
je suis assez fan du programme et le
moment fatidique dans mario premier
regard c'est quand les deux candidats se
voient pour la première fois je vous
rappelle le principe de personnes ne se
connaissent pas du tout elles vont se
voir et vont se marier directement grâce
à voilà à des trucs scientifique voilà
apparemment comptable de ce qu'on tombe
exactement des tests compatibilité et
regarder pour maxime sais pas vous mais
on est loin du coup de se regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est
clairement quand je les ai vus moi ce
qui m'a un peu déçu c'est
était pas forcément très grande l'idéal
féminin que je peux avoir c'est pas
forcément ça exactement
est ce que c'est vraiment la bonne
monsieur maxime font sentez vous
apprendre beaucoup et peu madame sonia
est si présente
[Musique]
oui
voyons pas nadia est ce que ça vous
choque que ça ah oui quoi c'est vrai
quoi alors en même temps on veut faire
du spectacle on veut faire mais j'aime
qu'il se pose la question où il est est
ce que c'est la bonne par exemple est ce
que vous pourriez c'était une connerie
avait franchement on pouvait voir
regarder mais je le ferai pas
franchement régime pourrais je le ferais
pas mais je peux m'adapter
oui je déteste cette émission mais je
peux moi me regardent comme suffire ah
oui j'adore regarder pas alors j'ai pas
dans le délire
j'aurais pu le faire alors vous matez
alors on va sur m6 mais j'aurais pu le
faire
je n'ai pu faire passer des tests
scientifiques d'étrangers au départ vous
avez le massif de logis c'est pas
bizarre tout ce que vous matez programme
bennent umoja pays
ah oui je sais c'est tout ce que je
déteste d'abord on parle de quelque
chose qui est important qui est
l'institution du mariage et il en parle
comme de koh lanta c'est à dire aux
jetons telle aventure et je vais voir
aussi en troisième semaine de jeu reste
mais non pardon et humoriste non mais
pour moi ça n'a pas que dans cette
émission et franchement on a
l'impression de candidats de télé
réalité qui ferait 12 et qui ont choisi
de faire celle ci parce que c'est un
tout petit peu soi disant scientifiques
jamais mais j'aimerais bien que l'amour
ce n'est pas se regarder l'un l'autre
mais sur l'ir d ensemble dans la même
direction et ont 19e c'est pas vrai qui
a dit st antoine de saint-exupéry alors
messieurs merci parce qu'elles font des
cours de philosophie il extrapole de
psychologie c'est là ils sont télé je
poussais un format original ans on
n'avait jamais vu ça avant
franchement je préfère voir sa cnib en
1e d'émissions de cuisine là franchement
c'est drôle et sûrs plus juste on sait
ça correspond concept c'est pas fort le
physique n'est pas forcément le plus
important des compatibilités qui font
que ils vont finir par tomber amoureux
et ça se vérifie souvent